time for some comedy with new rules
alright there were all the Tokyo
covenant makes this futon overcoat yes a
futon overcoat that get this then
becomes a bed must realize it will never
catch on here in America there's no
beverage holder neural hole since fading
celebrities Michael Phelps and Amanda
Bynes were both arrested for DUI this
week Dancing with the Stars must merge
with uber and the car service lifts must
merge with Kenny Rogers to become
facelift new rule just because you plop
your kid down in front of an iPad
instead of a TV doesn't mean you're not
a bad parent
although I must say dammit if it doesn't
work kids and restaurants these days
silent kids at the grocery store
comatose on the plane
zombies sure you're sad like them with
the future of attachment disorders and
ADHD but look on the bright side you
couldn't afford college anyway
new rule if the protesters in Hong Kong
want our support hello English we don't
look at this and want to join your cause
we look at this and think does that come
with fried rice new rule Illinois
congressman Aaron Schock has to either
ugly it up a little or yes that's a
congressman yeah either ugly up a little
or explain how Lindsey Graham is
supposed to get any work done around
here